Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du, vierhundertvierte Sendung, was was war jetzt vier null vier nochmal?
Äh habe ich auch gegoogelt, aber ich habe da irgendwie nix zu gefunden.
Buchnetzpolitik Nummer 4nullvier, da ist es also nun. Die tolle Zahl, Höhe und.
Ja
Ja, das auf jeden Fall äh viel Raum für Flachbetze. Ähm und man muss wirklich aufpassen, dass man da.
Mein, also mein, mein eigentlicher Vorschlag, hier eine Sendung anzulegen und einfach keine Audiodatei in den Feed zu geben, äh wurde von Tim abgelehnt aufgrund der Sorge
dass es vielleicht dann doch ein paar Beschwerden geben könnte. Von Unkundigen, die sich wundern, dass eine Fehlermeldung äh auftaucht und äh deswegen haben wir das nicht gemacht.
Dafür können sie ja trotzdem noch machen. Und dann kommt ihr erst später.
Ja werden wir dann sehen.
Wer also einen Fehler gesehen hat, jetzt wisst ihr warum.
Ja, herzlich willkommen bei dem Podcast, äh der auch noch die dümmsten Witze erklären muss. Aber wir hatten, wir hatten uns ja vorgenommen, äh dem dem Status quo, dem Status quo zu huldigen, also huldigen wir dem jetzt äh auch und natürlich ist vier null vier so das Ding.
Was irgendwie alle äh am meisten sehen und irgendwie auch am meisten fühlen. Und eine der Grunderkenntnisse oder das Internet äh
ich schon sehr früh äh gehabt habe, seitdem nicht äh nicht faul bin, jedem permanent unter die Nase zu reiben, als wo meine persönliche Weisheit ist, dass man Dinge im Internet sehr gut finden kann.
Ja, aber mit dem Wiederfinden, das ist immer so eine Sache
So, ich gehe dann da schnell äh verschüttet, ne. Kennst das, habe ich mal im Internet gelesen und so.
Haben wir nicht auch so einen so ein Plug-in bei uns, was bei den Shownotes sagt, welche Längs da überhaupt noch leben.
Ja, ja, das meckert die ganze Zeit.
Ja, also die die Shownotes stimmen ja zum Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung und werden dann regelmäßig auf Konsistenz geprüft. Und da wirft auch inzwischen vieles, äh, vier, null, vier.
Vor allem die Tagesschau. Hier ist irgendwie auch im Jahr 20 21.
Echt? Haben die keine stabilen Links?
Das ist immer wenn's aktuell ist, ist es so, dann irgendwann ändern sie es dann fürs Archiv und das verstehe ich einfach nicht, was was genau an dem Wort Permalink jetzt eigentlich so schwer zu verstehen ist.
Ja der Uniform Resource Low Cater äh ist halt gut, wenn man äh wenn er einfach konsistent bleibt.
Wir brauchen einfach digitale Permakultur, das ist.
Das ist das, was irgendwie gelernt werden muss, aber ich glaube, die Hoffnung, dass hier irgendwas gelernt wird, haben wir eh schon vor längerer Zeit an der Garderobe abgegeben. Na ja, bringt uns zu äh.
Unserem Gast nämlich Julia Reeder, hallo. Julia.
Hi. Ja, ich hoffe, dass äh ich jetzt dabei sein kann und die Folge nicht irgendwie in einer Fehlermeldung verschwindet. Das wäre sehr schade, aber.
Verschütt geht. Nee, wir können für gar nichts, ja, das wäre schade. Aber wir können für nichts garantieren. Es tut mir leid.
Freue ich mich aber schon mal da zu sein.
Genau, wenn da was gefunden wird, dann wirst du gefunden. Denn du bist ja auch äh nach wie vor ausreichend sichtbar mit deinen ganzen Aktivitäten und deswegen haben wir äh dich auch eingeladen.
Denn du solltest uns mal äh berichten rund um den hier auch schon vor einiger Zeit, ich weiß gar nicht, wann wir das schon mal aufgegriffen hatten. Vor ein paar Wochen auf jeden Fall. Äh den Fall
rund um äh Quart 9, also diesen
Äh DNS äh Provider, den man alternativ verwenden kann, wenn man mit seinen eigenen ähm Resolvern nicht äh glücklich ist, die verklagt wurden und da bist du ja schwer hinterher hinter dem Fall.
Richtig.
Ja, also bei diesem Fall gibt's Neuigkeiten, aber ich äh erzähle vielleicht erstmal nochmal, worum es geht in dem Gericht zu erfahren.
Also die äh Sony Music Entertainment Germany GmbH, also eins der großen äh hat eine einstweilige Verfügung erwirkt beim Landgericht Hamburg. Also ähm,
Das heißt, irgendwie so ein Eilverfahren, ohne dass äh Quad 9 in diesem Verfahren überhaupt bisher angehört wurde,
und hat eben verlangt, dass äh Quad 9 nach den Grundsätzen der Störerhaftung für Urheberrechtsverletzungen auf Webseiten dritter haften soll,
und eben verpflichtet werden soll,
Netsperren dagegen einzusetzen. Und das Landgericht Hamburg ist dem gefolgt. Also das heißt bei so einem so einer einstweiligen Verfügung,
man erstmal gar nichts machen, also war verpflichtet äh die den Zugang zu einer Webseite für User in Deutschland zu sperren.
Und ähm das ist gar nicht so einfach für so ein.
International agierenden DNS Reserver, also äh speichert ja nicht irgendwie wer das jetzt benutzt oder was für Seiten aufgerufen werden oder sonst irgendwas, ist ja gerade irgendwie ein Privatsphäre freundlicher Dienst,
und es ist eigentlich auch überhaupt nicht vorgesehen, dass man unterscheidet, aus welchem Land jetzt eine Webseite aus auf gerufen wird.
Aber ähm ja, das hat das Landgericht alles nicht so in Erwägung gezogen, sondern hat gesagt, na ja ähm.
Das werdet ihr schon hinkriegen und außerdem, dass eben diese dieser DNS-Dienst von der Störerhaftung betroffen ist. Und ähm.
Weiß nicht, einige Leute, die sich vielleicht erinnern, denken sich, hm, Störerhaftung war doch abgeschafft oder so,
das war irgendwie vor ein paar Jahren, da ging's vor allen Dingen um die freien WLANs und da hat der Bundestag im Telemediengesetz eigentlich gesagt, dass Internetzugangsanbieter nicht für Urheberrechtsverletzungen dritter in die Haftung genommen werden können,
und das Landgericht Hamburg sagt jetzt aber, naja, der DNS Dienst ist kein Internetzugangsanbieter.
Und ja, das ist erstmal die Situation. Also äh diese einstweilige Verfügung ist in Kraft.
Und ähm gegen die wollen wir jetzt mit der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte Widerspruch einlegen.
Würde ich eine mutige Feststellung, dass es kein Zugangsanbieter ist, weil ich will mal sehen, wie sie ohne DNS-Server irgendwie Zugang zum Internet bekommen.
Ja, also das ist natürlich völlig absurd.
DNS abschalten und gucken, ob man da nicht einfach durch einen kurzen Ausfall des DNS-Servers äh da eine eine Erkenntnis herbeiführen kann, ne.
Ja, sie kennen die IP-Adressen ja sicherlich auswendig.
Haben sie dir nicht im Hausfall stehen? Ähm vielleicht müssen wir einmal noch ganz kurz erklären für.
Also die, die einstweilige Verfügung, ich ich fand das als als Rechtsmittel ist das ja sehr interessant, weil.
Die wird ja eigentlich nur so ein bisschen grob formal geprüft, ob da ungefähr ein Anspruch äh klar ist und dann wird er, wird die einem einfach zugestellt. Also ähm und da wird dann einfach gesagt, so hiermit ist dir jetzt Folgendes, ist jetzt,
Entschieden vom Gericht, weil hohe Dringlichkeit besteht. Das ist ja nur für diese Fälle eigentlich gedacht, die einstweilige Verfügung, ne? Und dann ist sie eben,
Es wurde etwas verfügt und das wurde erstmal, also einstweilig verfügt und man kann dann sagen, alles klar, mache ich oder man kann sagen, ne,
sehe ich nicht ein, hier wurde,
falsch vorgetragen von der Antragstellerin oder so, ne? Und dann dann kommt es eben auch relativ zeitnah zu einer ähm zu einem zu einer Verhandlung über den über den Sachverhalt, ne?
Genau, also so funktioniert das im Wesentlichen. Ähm,
bei der einstweiligen Verfügung muss irgendwie eine Dringlichkeit gegeben sein und da kann man sich jetzt schon ein bisschen drüber streiten, ob das überhaupt der Fall ist. Also es geht um um eine Webseite, die auch ähm
bereits von der Clearingstelle Urheberrecht im Internet äh seit einiger Zeit gesperrt wird, also die,
Deutschen, Internetprovider, haben schon DNS-Sperren gegen diese Webseite und die Webseite besteht jetzt auch nicht seit gestern, ja? Also insofern ähm,
sich schon drüber streiten, wie dringend das Ganze ist. Also Sony ähm argumentiert halt, na ja,
dort sei ein Musikalbum veröffentlicht worden, was halt erst vor kurzer Zeit rausgekommen ist und begründen daran die Dringlichkeit,
Ja, eigentlich ähm sollten solche, solche Eilverfahren irgendwie auf offensichtliche und wirklich dringende Fälle beschränkt sein, weil,
eben die Gegenseite keine Chance hat, sich zu den Vorwürfen zu äußern, bevor diese diese einstweilig Verfügung ergeht. Und das ist natürlich erstmal ein großes Problem,
gerade wenn's irgendwie um so 'n.
Finanzierten, gemeinnützigen Dienstweg, also dass er kein großes Unternehmen, was dahinter steht, wie jetzt zum Beispiel, also wenn das beim,
DNS äh Dienst von Google passiert wäre, dann könnte man sagen, na ja, die müssen sich vor Gerichtskosten keine Sorgen machen,
aber äh bei so einem kleinen Dienst natürlich ist es erstmal kostengünstiger,
so 'ne einstweiligen Verfügung zu entsprechen als wirklich dann auch den Widerstand Widerspruch dagegen einzulegen,
und ähm es auf eine Entscheidung nach einer mündlichen Verhandlung ankommen zu lassen, weil dann halt gleich erstmal ja Gerichtskosten, Anwaltskosten und so weiter auf die zukommen,
Und das ist auch der Grund, also weshalb wir von der GFF uns entschieden haben, die dabei zu unterstützen, weil das einfach eine ganz, ganz wichtige Grundsatzfrage ist. Und wenn man das jetzt einfach so stehen lässt und sagt, ja, äh Störerhaftung gilt für DNS Dienste,
dann gilt es wahrscheinlich morgen auch für, weiß nicht, Antivirensoftware, Browser,
es gibt ja alle möglichen Intermediären, die irgendwie dazu beitragen, dass 'ne Webseite erreichbar ist und wenn die alle jetzt für die Urheberrechtsdurchsetzung,
in Anspruch genommen werden können, dann haben wir, glaube ich, noch ein ganz größeres Problem.
Jetzt wissen wir natürlich auch, glaube ich, nochmal ganz kurz erklären, was ist DNS und was ist Quad neun? Also DNS, wir haben's ja schon ein bisschen angedeutet, ist die Übersetzung von Domainnamen,
zu IP-Adressen, also im Fall von äh Logbuch Netzpolitik. Wenn man jetzt mal so guckt, äh ich mache das mal eben.
Minus Netzpolitik DE, ne? Dann fragt mein Computer einen DNS-Server
und der antwortet und sagt übrigens, die IP-Adresse für Logbuch Netzpolitik ist
eins drei acht Punkt zwei null eins Punkt acht null Punkt sechs acht. In dem Fall eine IP V vier Adresse, weil ich nach IPV4 gefragt habe und dann sagt mein Computer verbindet sich ja zu der IP-Adresse und sagt, ich möchte gerne
die Webseite Logbuchnetzpolitik DE sehen und kriegt er die zurück. Und,
jetzt den DNS-Server, also jede von euch hat einen gesetzt.
Wahrscheinlich wird die überwiegende Mehrheit einfach den Nutzen, den der, der vom ISP vorgegeben wird.
Und wahrscheinlich wird die werden viele andere von euch dann den DNS-Server von Google oder Cloudflair nutzen, das ist dann wenn man.
8 8 äh acht acht oder eins eins als DNS-Server benutzt.
Und jetzt gibt's eben hier dieses diese Gruppe die haben eben den DNS-Server neun neun neun.
Und sagen, ja äh frei äh freie Sicherheit und hohe Privatsphäre äh haben offenbar auch,
irgendwie, also sie, sie blocken auch äh IP-Adressen auf Basis von Fred Intelligence, also die sagen quasi wenn wir,
wissen, wenn wir Kenntnis davon erlangen, dass bestimmte Domainnamen im Rahmen von Angriffen
benutzt werden, dann lösen wir die einfach direkt nicht mehr auf. Was natürlich ein sehr gute äh also das ist ein muss ich mal sagen, wirklich ein tolles Angebot, ja, eben zu sagen, alles klar,
Ähm ich ich kann quasi hier, ich soll, ich kann mich nicht drauf verlassen, sollte das auch nicht als einzige Sicherheits ähm Basis haben, aber es ist schon gut,
bekanntermaßen bösartige Domains einfach von meinem DNS gar nicht aufgelöst werden, weil.
Im besten Fall tatsächlich das letzte Glück im schwerwiegenden Unglück sein kann, dass äh eben so eine bösartige Domain nicht aufge,
rufen wird und eben eine Schadsoftware von dort nicht nachgeladen werden kann oder keine Verbindung zum Commadin Cottfort Server hergestellt wird.
Also es ist eigentlich schon relativ cool, was die machen.
Ja und das ist halt kostenlos, also äh steht auch keine Firma dahinter, wie jetzt irgendwie bei Google oder Cloudflair,
und ist halt spendenfinanziert, also rechtlich gesehen ist Quartein eine Stiftung nach Schweizer Recht. Ähm und ja, insofern,
Kann man sich jetzt auch fragen, also warum,
zornmäßig den kleinen, gemeinnützigen Spendenfinanzierten Dienst für diese einstweilige Verfügung rausgesucht hat, vor allen Dingen,
wie du schon richtig sagst, äh mehr Leute benutzen, andere DNS Reserve, also insofern, wenn's einem wirklich darum geht, maximal gut äh die Verbreitung von Urheberrechtsverletzungen zu verhindern
ist das wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt jetzt der erste Dienst, der einem in den Weg äh kommt. Aber ähm ich glaube, du sprichst eine ganz wichtige Sache an
auch vielleicht das das Landgericht äh Hamburg so ein bisschen verwirrt hat, dass äh die sagen, naja, nein, filtert ja bereits bestimmte Domains,
Warum ist es dann ein Problem zusätzlich dann noch auch noch äh Urheberrechtsverletzungen zu filtern,
Und da muss man, glaube ich, so ein bisschen noch mal technisch ähm differenzieren. Also das eine Ding ist, diese Malware-Filterung,
anbietet, die ist komplett unter der Kontrolle des Users. Also äh neun neun neun ist quasi die Standardadresse für den DNS Reserver von ähm.
Der halt dieses Sicherheitsfeature anbietet, aber es gibt auch den Ungefilterten Dienst, ich glaube, dass dann neun, neun, neun, zehn und das heißt, du entscheidest selber als Nutzerin, äh ob du jetzt diese Filterung haben willst oder nicht,
und der andere vielleicht noch äh äh wichtigere Punkt ist,
nicht selber entscheidet ähm was für Merwas sie jetzt blocken wollen, sondern die bekommen halt solche Listen von unabhängigen Sicherheitsorganisationen,
ähm eingespielt und diese Listen gelten global,
Das heißt also, da wird nicht unterschieden, ist das jetzt irgendwie ein User aus Deutschland, der da irgendwas aufrufen will oder,
woanders her, sondern das sind halt ja, stehen quasi anerkannte Sicherheitsorganisationen dahinter, die sagen, diese äh Domains wurden oder diese IP-Adressen wurden mit Phishing-Attacken,
in Verbindung gebracht und die sperren wir jetzt auf Wunsch des und das ganze weltweit,
und mit mit derselben Technologie kann man jetzt nicht das umsetzen, was das Landgericht Hamburg verlangt, nämlich diese eine Domain,
auf der eine Urheberrechtsverletzung äh nachgewiesen werden kann, darf für User in Deutschland nicht mehr aufrufbar sein.
Er hat noch ganz kurz mit diesem mit diesem Blocking, ne, dass ähm,
Das ist eigentlich ein Service, also große Organisationen, ähm die kaufen sich das.
Die die haben das dann in ihrem Lokalnetz und diese diese Fred Intelligence beschränkt sich ja nicht notwendigerweise nur auf Domains, äh sondern vielleicht auch auf,
oder wird bestimmte Formen von anderen Indicaters of Compromis oder sonstigen. Den kleinen Teil, der die Domains betrifft, den
kriegt hier wahrscheinlich Quad 9 von diesen,
kostenlos, vermute ich, zur Verfügung gestellt und macht ihnen damit eine äh ja den Bereich der, sagen wir mal, kleineren Unternehmen und der,
Privatperson auf diesem Weg äh zugänglich als.
Und da muss man ja auch sagen, ne, ist das jetzt Zensur? Nein, ist es nicht, weil es ja eine bestellte Einschränkung ist, für die sich die Nutzerinnen entscheiden, ne? Und sagen, okay, ich nutze neun, neun, neun, neun,
oder ich nutze neun neun zehn oder neun neun elf, je nachdem welche Art von Service-Level ich dort äh bekomme. Und
das heißt ja nicht, dass die bestellt haben, ich möchte übrigens auch nochmal äh hier die die Interessen von Sony Entertainment äh vertreten haben und vielleicht auch noch die von der von der Bäckerblume oder so, ne? Das ist ja spezifisch nicht der Fall.
Genau, also das ist der Unterschied. Einmal diese Filterung ist freiwillig für den Nutzer, der es benutzt und sie ist global einheitlich, weil's da halt um Sicherheitstrets geht und nicht darum, ob irgendwas jetzt in einer Juristik möglicherweise illegal ist oder nicht.
Jetzt hast du äh also was wie das juristische Vorgehen, wie du schon sagst, die nehmen sich hier irgendeinen kleinen, ich muss zu zugegebenermaßen sagen, Asche auf mein Haupt, ich kannte die vorher nicht.
Wenn ich mir anschaue, was die hier anbieten.
Bin ich da sehr für sehr dran interessiert, das jetzt mal hier äh im Heimnetz ähm zur Anwendung zu bringen, was die hier anbieten.
Ähm.
Wollen doch wahrscheinlich mit, also mit diesem Vorgehen, sag mal, einer kleinen, gemeinnützigen Organisation ohne Profitinteresse, mit einer einstweiligen reinzuwürgen, das sieht doch danach aus, dass die einfach präzedent schaffen wollen, oder?
Ja, also das kann schon sein. Ich glaube, also man kann schauen aus der Perspektive von so einem kleinen Anbieter, was für Optionen denen freistehen. Weil ähm
Es ist ja unwahrscheinlich, dass es bei dieser einen äh Sperrforderung bleiben wird. Ähm entweder sie können,
im Vorauseilenden Gehorsam, wenn sie so eine Abmahnung bekommen, äh global sperren, weil das halt technisch wesentlich leichter durchführbar ist,
oder sie können letzten Endes sagen, okay, wir
bieten den Dienst jetzt in Deutschland nicht mehr an. Also ähm hat auch irgendwie einen Server in Deutschland. Das heißt also, wenn ich äh diesen DNS-Reserver benutze
dann werden meine Anfragen auch nicht aus Deutschland rausgeleitet. Ähm das könnten sie möglicherweise halt in Zukunft nicht mehr machen,
was halt echt absurd ist, also man muss auch dazu wissen, die EU Kommission zum Beispiel hat gerade eine Ausschreibung laufen für einen europäischen DNS Resort, äh weil die weniger abhängig sein wollen von Google und Go.
Also das heißt, es gibt ein echtes Privatsphäreinteresse daran, dass es europäische DNS-Dienste gibt, die auch lokal betrieben werden,
Und äh dann sollte man denen vielleicht nicht durch solche Haftungs äh Regelungssteine in den Weg legen. Also ähm das ist, denke ich, völlig klar. Und mit der globalen Sperrung ähm.
Also das hat Courtney jetzt nicht gemacht. Also die Domain, um die es geht, äh die mussten sie jetzt sperren, weil diese äh einstweilige Verfügung sie dazu verpflichtet, nach deutschem Recht.
Und sie haben halt jetzt wirklich ihr System umgebaut, um manuell, also möglichst für User, die,
aus Deutschland versuchen auf diese Webseite zu zugreifen, die nicht aufzulösen, was halt einfach ja ungenau ist, weil so genau wissen die gar nicht, wer jetzt aus Deutschland kommt, also kann man mehr oder weniger raten,
anhand der IP vielleicht, ähm.
Und äh das Ganze macht das System auch langsamer. Also ähm weil das einfach so nicht vorgesehen ist, dass man halt ähm äh so eine global äh lokale Unterscheidung trifft,
und bei einer Domain ist das vielleicht noch zu verkraften,
aber ähm wir wissen ja bereits, dass äh die Rechteinhaberverbände in Deutschland wesentlich weitgehendere Pläne, für denen es Sperren haben. Also wir haben auch schon mal über die geredet, ne, von paar Folgen, glaube ich.
Welche welche Domain äh müssen sie sperren?
Das ist eine der Domains, die auch von der gesperrt wird, also ist halt eine von äh äh diesen.
Ja, also ich ich will jetzt nicht Werbung machen, sage ich mal, für für diese Webseiten,
Aber wenn man irgendwie auf Punkt Info geht, das ist irgendwie dieser Zusammenschluss von Rechteinhabern und dann Empfehlungen, dann sieht man halt die Webseiten, die
von denen gesperrt werden. Ähm,
und also wir haben auch das vielleicht ganz interessant für den Hintergrund, also die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte setzt sich auch relativ kritisch,
auseinander, also weil das halt ein privater Zusammenschluss von deutschen Rechteinhabern und ähm Internetzugangsanbietern ist, die also sozusagen freiwillig Netzsperren ähm miteinander vereinbaren.
Und ähm die, also da haben wir eine Informationsfreiheitsanfrage gemacht ans Bundeskartellamt,
und haben eine Liste von 170 Domains bekommen, die die Kui plant, zu sperren in nächster Zeit.
Aber die die also ich suche die gerade auf deren Webseite, da finde ich die nicht.
Welche Liste jetzt?
Ah doch, warte mal hier, sie haben Empfehlungen.
Genau. Und da siehst du dann so ein paar Domains. Und das ist halt eine von denen. Also ähm so eine Musik äh Download-Seite quasi.
Guck mal. Also ich vermute, dass ich grade alle auflösen kann hier aus Deutschland, weil ich.
Hast du hast du wahrscheinlich äh das ist ja auch äh der Witz dabei. Also.
Selbst wenn, selbst wenn, also das ist ja noch äh äh die Ironie der Geschichte, wenn du so ein DNS Resort war,
installiert hast, also da muss man vielleicht auch nochmal den Unterschied zwischen DNS Server und DNS Reserver ähm erklären und der DNS Rollsorver kann deine Anfrage nicht beantworten, dann hast du meistens noch einen zweiten,
Reserver als Backup ähm eingerichtet und wenn der das auflösen kann, dann wird dir die Webseite trotzdem angezeigt. Also das heißt, die Sperre.
Ich frage jetzt spezifisch Kurt neun, also und ich habe jetzt hier vier Domains gefunden. Ich frage Quart 9 und die Antworten mir. Das liegt aber im Zweifelsfall daran, dass ich nicht aus Deutschland gerade komme. Für, für sie.
Daran wird's wahrscheinlich liegen, ja. Ja. Bei aus Deutschland wäre die sonst gesperrt.
Also wenn ich dadrauf wenn ich da drauf gehe, kriege ich tatsächlich diese Sperrseite. Diese Webseite ist Hausurheberrechtlichen Gründen nicht verfügbar. Das ist jetzt ein Telekom äh DNS, den ich hier verwende.
Genau. Genau, also das muss man auch dazu wissen. Also die deutschen Internet-Provider und deren DNS-Server, die blocken diese Webseite bereits.
Ja und wenn ich aber über Google gehe, äh aber auch.
Sie wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wenn ich über gehe, kriege ich eine andere IP-Adresse, die dann wahrscheinlich die richtige ist.
Ach so, ich habe jetzt nur die Auflösung gemacht. Das kann natürlich sein, warte mal, nicht dass sie mir,
Also nicht, dass ich einfach davon ausgegangen bin, dass weil ich eine Antwort bekomme, sie stimmt, Sekunde. Aber ich habe jetzt vier Domains geprüft und kriege.
Für alle vier eine andere Antwort, ja. Also ich kriege richtige richtiges.
Okay. Also ich habe das hier mal ausprobiert und ich habe äh glaube ich bekommen oder.
Okay, aber keine, ich will hier keine.
Ich komme aus anderen Teilen Europas, will sagen, dass äh funktioniert gerade. Halb, also das funktioniert wahrscheinlich, aber äh.
Natürlich auch eine einfache Umgehungsmöglichkeit äh zwei haben wir jetzt genannt, einfach Google benutzen oder ähm.
Oder eben durch ein VPN irgendwo anders herkommen, äh DNS-Auflösung durch Tor geht genauso und ähm.
Ja, ansonsten, wer all das nicht kann, einmalig äh auflösen und die IP-Adressen ins Haus fallen, äh funktioniert auch.
Also ich glaube die Schnittmenge der Leute, die einerseits technisch versiert genug sind, um sich selber ein DNS Reserver auszusuchen,
aber andererseits nicht technisch versiert genug sind, äh einen Fehler dann auch äh zu umgehen, ist wahrscheinlich relativ klein.
Aber ist auch eine ziemlich freche Webseite, muss man sagen. Also es ist einfach wirklich so. Hier hast du Album, nimm Lat.
Also äh das muss man, glaube ich, auch dazu sagen, nein, geht's überhaupt nicht dadrum, irgendwie äh äh weiß nicht, Urheberrechtsverletzungen
gut zu heißen oder so, sondern es geht halt darum, wer ist dafür verantwortlich die Rechtsdurchsetzung zu machen? Und da hat der deutsche Gesetzgeber ziemlich deutlich gesagt, vor einigen Jahren, da ging's um Freifunk,
wie wir wollen nicht, dass Internetzugangsanbieter von der Störerhaftung betroffen werden, weil einfach der Schaden für die Gesellschaft,
zu groß ist, also dass diese Abmahnkosten drohen, dass die Gerichtskosten drohen. Ähm.
Und wir deshalb sagen, wir befreien Internetzugangsanbieter, die selber ja nicht Schuld daran sind, wenn jemand Urheberrechtsverletzung auf einer Webseite begeht, von dieser Störerhaftung,
und ähm ja, es ist mir einfach nicht ersichtlich, warum für ein DNS Resort, der halt einfach wirklich notwendig ist, um den Internetzugang auch zu nutzen, warum da dann jetzt was anderes gelten sollte.
Also muss ja sagen, die Störerhaftung geht ja in dem Fall sogar noch weiter und da gibt es also das Problem ist,
juristisch oder legislativ gelöst, leider aber noch nicht bei den Gesetzen Entschuldigung, leider noch nicht bei den Gericht,
angekommen. Das heißt, das Problem ist in der Legislative geklärt, in der Rechtssprechung äh hapert's da aber leider auch immer noch. Da ist der Fall störerhaftung. Du bietest jemand anderem,
dein WLAN an, diese Person nutzt das, begeht dabei eine Urheberrechtsverletzung, Beispielsweise über wird dann abgemahnt und jetzt ist die Situation,
haftest du dafür, was Menschen über deine Internetverbindung getan haben? Und würde man mit dieser Argumentation an die Deutsche Telekom herantreten,
Ja und sagen, so, pass mal auf, du hast den Leuten Internet gegeben, Katastrophe, die haben jetzt darüber hier dieses Album geteilt, was.
Und uns ist dadurch ein Schaden von einer Mark achtzig entstanden, weil es nicht gestreamt wurde. Ähm das wäre natürlich lustig. Ne, aber solche äh solche.
Präzedenzfälle versuchst du natürlich strategisch lieber mit kleinen schwachen herbeizuführen,
um dann eventuell eben an die Deutsche Telekom herantreten zu können und zu sagen, passt auf Leute, wenn ihr nicht so macht, wie wir das wollen, oder an Google, dann wisst ihr, wie deutsche Gerichte darüber urteilen. Wir haben,
Präzedenz, also würde ich an deren,
an deren Stelle genauso machen, dass ich mir erstmal irgendeinen kleinen Schwachen hole, um irgendwie ja eine einschläge Rechtssprengung herbeizuführen und nicht,
so einen Fall mit den Anwältinnen von Google äh ausdiskutieren zu müssen, die sicherlich ähm einstweilige Verfügungen sehr gerne,
ähm äh in ihrer äh in ihrer äh Mittagspause noch kurz äh abwatschen. Also es ist schon sehr sehr durchschaubar, was hier eigentlich.
Von Seiten Sony geplant ist, oder?
Ja, also ich meine, ähm ich, ich vermute mal, dass langfristig das Ziel von diesen Verbänden ist,
also Sony Music ist ja ein Teil vom Bundesverband Musikindustrie, der ist wiederum Mitglied der dass das in Zukunft alles ohne Beteiligung der Gerichte geregelt wird. Also so wie du sagst, dass man halt einfach an
äh diversen Provider herantritt und sagt, hier sperrt doch mal freiwillig auf Zuruf,
damit euch gar nicht erst die Gerichtskosten drohen. Also in diesem Fall jetzt mit Quart Nein, ist es sogar noch ein bisschen ähm problematischer, weil äh es auch so.
Offene Fragen über die Vorgehensweise von Sony gibt, also Sony hat halt dem Gericht gesagt,
Wir haben Courtney abgemahnt, kostenpflichtig und die haben darauf nicht reagiert, aber tatsächlich ähm äh sagt Quad nein, dass diese Abmahnung nie bei ihnen angekommen ist. Also es gibt auch solche,
ganz, ganz offensichtlichen faktischen Probleme bei diesem Fall. Und insofern also finde ich das auch,
wichtig, sich dagegen zur Wehr zu setzen, weil halt gesagt wurde, na ja, wir haben's irgendwie äh,
Tour versucht und äh das hat nicht funktioniert oder so. Also tatsächlich ähm.
Wusste grad nein, überhaupt nichts von diesem Verfahren, bis halt die Post vom Gericht kam. Und das ist natürlich auch äh noch mal besonders heftig. Also wenn man halt so einen Dienst betreibt und in dem Moment, wo das Gericht die einstweilige Verfügung verhängt hat, ähm,
ist natürlich das Kostenrisiko schon viel, viel größer, als wenn man einfach nur eine E-Mail bekommen hat und gesagt hat, irgendwie äh hier ist eine Abmahnung oder so,
Aber auch die Abmahnkosten können natürlich nicht unerheblich sein für so einen Spenden finanzierten Dienst, deshalb ähm,
das ja auch abgeschafft mit den mit also zumindest was Freifunkt anging und.
Ja, also ich halte diese Argumentation, dass es auf DNS-Dienste nicht anwendbar wäre für äh ziemlich weit hergeholt.
Jetzt muss er natürlich sagen, ich, also ich find's ganz interessant, die Abmahnungen im Bereich des sind ja schon seit langer Zeit.
Sagen wir mal für die Musikindustrie ein ein Profitcenter
ja, die man ja immer zu irgendwelchen vierstelligen Beträgen ab immer mit äh eins, zwei Kanzleien, die diesen Prozess äh industrialisiert haben.
Waldorf Frommer ist die eine, ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau wie die andere heißt und das ist 'n das ist halt 'ne.
Das eine eigene Business Unit, die halt diesen Prozess industrialisiert hat und halt natürlich von jedem Menschen, der da irgendwie mal in so einem Fall Sharing äh erwischt wurde, viel mehr Geld bekommt, als,
die verdient hätten mit ihrer blöden Musik, wenn äh
oder als ihnen entgangen ist, dadurch, dass was weiß ich, 2hundert Leute äh diese Musik geteilt haben, ne, dass das äh also die Abmahnung als die freundliche Option zu sehen, finde ich hier auch äh lustig. Gleichzeitig kann ich verstehen, dass sie dann eben versuchen, diesen.
Ähm wie heißen die immer, diese Dienste? Die haben da immer so einen Namen, äh.
Also die, die wo's quasi links gibt zum traditionellen Herunterladen,
Ja, ähm File-Hoster oder was auch immer, ne? Die die haben natürlich den den Vorteil für die Nutzerinnen,
denen droht da keine Strafe. Ne, die haben irgendwas im Internet gefunden, haben da draufgeklickt. Das ist etwas, was üblicherweise den,
diesen Musikindustrie abmahnen Kanzleien eben verborgen bleibt und sie können dich dafür nicht belangen.
Was ja auch zum, wenn wir hier an die Fälle denken, Kino, TU, Kino, XTO und so weiter. Ähm.
In dem Zusammenhang übrigens auch darauf verwiesen, dass sind nicht die Guten, ja. Das sind äh gerade bei Kino XTO war das ja wirklich auch eine.
Ja, die haben das halt zum Geschäftsmodell gemacht, das sind nicht irgendwelche äh Copyleft äh Aktivistinnen, die man mit 200 Leuten ein Album teilen oder so, sondern das sind das war eben eine,
ja Organisation, die sich da, die das wirtschaftlichen mit wirtschaftlichen Zielen betrieben hat und entsprechend natürlich auch irgendwann hochgenommen wurde.
Hatte aber eben den Vorteil für die Nutzerinnen ohne rechtliches Risiko zu sein. Das nur so zum.
Gefüge des. So, die GFF hat sich also jetzt entschieden, den Fall zu.
Zu begleiten, zu verteidigen, welche Ziele setzt ihr euch dabei.
Also
eine ganze Reihe von wichtigen Rechtsfragen, die wir hier klären müssen. Also einmal wollen wir erreichen, dass äh gerichtlich festgestellt wird, dass DNS-Dienste
natürlich unter den Haftungsausschuss des Telemediengesetzes fallen. Also das ist ja so ein so ein
Grundsatz der Internetgesetzgebung auch durch europäisches Recht vorgegeben. In der E-Commerce-Richtlinie, dass eben diese sogenannten Intermediären erstmal nicht haften für äh die Inhalte, die dritte
über ihre Dienste verbreiten. Ähm in Deutschland ist das halt irgendwie im im Telemediengesetz und ähm.
Da wollen wir eben klarstellen, dass wenn einerseits gesagt wird, der DNS-Dienst ist irgendwie genug an der Urheberrechtsverletzung beteiligt. Allein dadurch, dass er die IP-Adresse auflöst,
Dann muss diese Beteiligung auch ausreichend sein dafür, dass er eben als Internetzugangsanbieter gilt. Weil man kann's nicht irgendwie äh so so charypicking betreiben, dass man einerseits sagt, ja eher DNS-Dienst ähm,
Zugang zu den urheberrechtlichen Inhalten und deshalb ist er haftbar, aber andererseits bereitet er keinen Zugang zu den urheberrechtlichen Inhalten und deshalb ist er nicht von der Störerhaftung befreit, also das geht nicht. Das ist der eine Punkt,
Ganz wichtiger anderer Punkt ist auch, dass Netzsperren vom Europäischen Gerichtshof aus grundrechtlichen Gründen nur unter ganz bestimmten Voraussetzungen erlaubt wurden. Also ähm.
Das Netzsperren in der EU überhaupt erlaubt sind, ähm kann man sich auch drüber streiten, ob das äh grundrechtlich so gut ist,
aber ähm das ist keinesfalls so, dass äh der EuGH einen Blanko-Shake gegeben hat und sagt, Netzsperren sind grundrechtlich unproblematisch. Das war damals irgendwie UPC Telekabel, das Urteil,
Da hat der EuGH gesagt, also es müssen ein paar Voraussetzungen erfüllt sein. Unter anderem muss äh die Gefahr von Overblocking,
ähm bekämpft werden, weil ähm es ist klar.
Oder vielleicht ist es auch nicht klar und ich sag's nochmal, dass äh so ein DNS-Dienst natürlich nicht einzelne urheberrechtlich geschützte Inhalte sperren kann,
Also ein DNS Dienst ähm löst immer nur IP-Adressen auf und äh die IP-Adressen gehören dann zu einer ganzen Domain,
und das heißt, wenn die gesperrt wird, dann sind alle Inhalte, die auf dieser Domain sind, nicht mehr verfügbar und nicht nur der eine, der irgendwie eine Urheberrechtsverletzung war,
Und äh da hat eben der Europäische Gerichtshof und später auch der Bundesgerichtshof gesagt, dass nur, also net sperren, nur in Frage kommen, wenn die illegalen Inhalte ganz klar überwiegen.
Und ähm das muss für den Dienst, der diese Sperre äh umsetzen soll, auch offensichtlich sein.
Und da fangen die Probleme natürlich schon an, wenn's sich um so einen globalen Dienst handelt,
dass er irgendwie in allen Rechtsordnungen der Welt, auf allen Sprachen der Welt irgendwie beurteilen können soll,
welche Webseiten insgesamt irgendwie strukturell Urheberrechtsverletzend sind und bei welchen möglicherweise nur einzelne Urheberrechtsverletzungen vorgekommen sind. Also äh,
immer wieder auch äh äh Streitigkeiten drüber, dass irgendjemand äh dann solche Webseiten wie das Internet, AK versucht als äh irgendwie äh Piraterie Webseiten abzustempeln, nur weil's dort halt einzelne Ulberrechtsverletzungen gibt.
Und ein anderer Punkt, den der Europäische Gerichtshof klargemacht hat, in diesem Kontext Overblocking ist, dass sich die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer immer gerichtlich gegen die Sperre wehren können müssen.
Und das ist bei Internetzugangsanbietern, also wenn die Deutsche Telekom jetzt eine Webseite sperrt.
Tatsächlich so, dass ich als Kundin bei der Telekom sie dann verklagen kann. Kann man sich natürlich drüber streiten, wer macht das, wer hat einerseits irgendwie äh,
die äh juristischen,
Kenntnisse, dass Geld und so weiter, um dann tatsächlich äh gegen die Telekom vor Gericht zu ziehen, aber das ist eine Voraussetzung, also dass quasi die Betroffenen von der Sperre die Möglichkeit haben, dagegen gerichtlich vorzugehen und die gerichtlich überprüfen zu lassen,
und das ist unserer Ansicht nach, nein, auch nicht gegeben, weil die haben ja gar keine Kundinnen in diesem Sinne. Also es ist nicht so, dass ich mit äh Quart Nein.
Vertrag unterschreibe, äh sondern das ist ein Dienst, der ist für alle.
Kostenfrei im Internet verfügbar. Ich muss mich nirgendwo anmelden, ich muss keine Termce of Service unterschreiben, sondern alles, was ich mache, ist halt neun, neun, neun, neun, in meinen Systemkonfigurationen einzugeben und schon benutze ich den Dienst.
Also das heißt, äh es gibt überhaupt keine Möglichkeit, wenn jetzt zu viel gesperrt wird,
dass ich irgendwie als als betroffene Nutzerin klagen kann und sagen kann, ich mir werden hier, mir wird hier Zugang zu Inhalten verwehrt oder so.
Mhm.
Wie sieht es aus mit denen, die gesperrt werden? Äh müssen die sich äh irgendwie, also die die müssen sich ja ebenfalls irgendwie,
Rechtshilfe den Rechtsweg bestreiten können. Ich gehe jetzt davon aus, dass eine Organisation, die potenziell im Verdacht steht, äh
gewerbsmäßig Urheberrechtsverletzungen voranzubringen, sich nicht über eine geeignete Rechtsform verfügt,
Um das mal vorsichtig zu sagen, aber in anderen Fällen ist das ja durchaus der Fall, ne? Oder wäre das ja denkbar?
Ja, also da da können immer Fehler passieren, also je nachdem auch, wie die wie die Hostingstruktur von so einer Webseite ist. Ich glaube, es ähm,
dass das Problem bei IP-Sperren größer ist, dass halt irgendwie völlig unzusammenhängende Dinge plötzlich nicht mehr erreichbar sind. Ich glaube, es gab's in Russland mal, dass irgendwie eine IP-Sperre
gegen irgendeinen Dienst verhängt wurde, der auf Amazon-Webservices gehostet war und plötzlich waren alle möglichen,
anderen Dienste auch gesperrt. Also es können immer Fehler passieren und natürlich äh äh sollte auch ein Betroffener Webseitenbetreiber gegen,
eine falsche Sperre vorgehen können,
Aber ähm also in in dieser EUGH Entscheidung ging's vor allen Dingen um diese Frage, dass äh die betroffenen Nutzerinnen und Nutzer irgendein ein Rechtsbehelfs äh zur Verfügung haben müssen,
und der ist unserer Ansicht nach hier nicht gegeben.
Also IP-Sperren auch immer eine eine sehr sehr schlechte Idee.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das äh kann man, glaube ich, uneingeschränkt äh unterschreiben.
Äh vor allem, ja, also vor allem wenn ich, also dass das Problem hat man halt gelöst mit,
mit einer sehr kurzlebigen DNS-Einträgen und dann springt man halt die ganze Zeit hin und her, grade wenn man auf Amazon AWS irgendwie eine eine Front hostet oder einfach Cloudflair davor hat, ähm.
Geht das einfach nicht mehr, ne? Das, also das, das sollte man tunlichst vermeiden.
Gibt's ja sehr schöne äh auch vielleicht historisch äh sehr schöne Versuche, wie mal Länder versucht haben, ähm
IP-Adressen quasi zu blockieren, indem sie das äh über das einfach äh kürzere Routen announct haben. Also,
im Prinzip das wie sich das Internet so ein bisschen halbwegs autonom strukturiert, wer wohin ruhten kann.
Und jedes jedes einzelne größere System sagt dann hier, pass auf, bei uns kommst du gut da und da hin. Und dann propagiert sich das so ein bisschen, weil dann alle.
Quasi sagen, okay, nee, wir hör mal, wenn du da in drei Hobs hast und der andere vier, dann gebe ich das mal zu dir. Und ich glaube, Türkei.
Haben mal vor ein paar Jahren gesagt, ah, wir sperren jetzt YouTube, weil's da irgendein Video gibt, wo der Prophet verunglimpft wird und haben einfach announced Hops zu den YouTube-Servern bei uns null, ja? Das hat.
Ganz kurz echt gut funktioniert, bis dann der Rest des Internets gesagt hat, okay, alles klar,
alle Leute, die nach YouTube fragen, schicken wir jetzt in die Türkei. Das heißt, sie haben am Ende ihr eigenes Land äh gedest, dadurch, dass sie gesagt haben, weil das hier quasi die kürzeste Route zu YouTube-Star.
Also IP-Sperren schwieriges, schwieriges Feld, ja? Schwierige.
Man nicht machen, ne.
Protokoll einfach als Internet-Navi zu beschreiben auf die Idee, bin ich bisher auch noch nicht gekommen. Aber es trifft's eigentlich ganz gut, ne?
Ja. Nee, aber also hier, hier geht's nur in Anführungszeichen um die DNS sperren, aber ähm.
Auch da muss man natürlich sagen, es gibt natürlich irgendwie andere Dienste, die wesentlich näher an an so einer Rechtsverletzung dran sind. Also man kann sich schon fragen, warum Sony nicht irgendwie zu dem Registry,
oder Registral gegangen ist, die diese Domain überhaupt vergeben haben. Die haben ja wenigstens mal eine Vertragsbeziehung mit äh diesem,
mit dieser Webseite gehabt, aber ein DNS Resort war halt wirklich keinerlei Ahnung, wer hinter dieser Webseite steckt, ähm.
Was da für Inhalte verbreitet werden, sie leiten die Inhalte noch nicht mal durch. Sie sind wirklich mehr oder weniger wie das Telefonbuch. Also ähm oder der DNS Resort ist nicht mal ein Telefonbuch, der stellt quasi nur den,
also fragt leitet eigentlich nur die Anfrage weiter, also du möchtest irgendwie Freiheitsrechte Punkt org aufrufen, der DNS Reserve hat entweder,
sozusagen schon zwischengespeichert was für 'ne IP-Adresse das ist oder er fragt dann halt den autoritativen Server,
Also weiter weg sein kann man von der Urheberrechtsverletzung eigentlich kaum,
und auch aus verhältnismäßigkeitsgrundsätzen, also wer es wirklich extrem fatal, wenn ein so weit entfernter,
intermediärer jetzt als Störer haften könnte. Also dann stellt sich wirklich die Frage, müssen in Zukunft irgendwie Firefox äh,
auch verhindern, dass bestimmte Webseiten aufgerufen werden, weil die sind vielleicht ähnlich weit von der Urheberrechtsverletzung entfernt.
Ich habe gerade kurz gegoogelt, das war Pakistan, die das mit YouTube gemacht haben. Das war 2008. Ich habe da meinen Blogpost zu gezeigt, aber ich weiß, dass die Türkei auch irgendwelche.
Ja, das gab's, gab's in mehreren Fällen, dass äh versucht wurde, so mit BGP, den Traffic, äh ich glaube auch, dass nicht China, die mal äh bewusst dann auch den Traffic durch ihr Land geleitet haben, um das.
Das war 2zehn. Und China war aber in der Lage, das auch zu routen. Das war den, den habe ich auch nochmal äh
verlinkt, dass China war irgendwie für einige am 8. April 2010 für 18 Minuten, 15 Prozent des gesamten Internet der Welt
gerutet.
Okay, also die haben sich äh nicht gedehnt. Die konnten das verkraften oder wie?
Ich glaube, die haben halt gesagt, so, wir müssen mal eine, wir machen mal eine Lastprobe. Wie machen wir die? Ja, wir einfach mal alle Ruten.
Sie haben ihr Ziel erreicht. Und haben ihr Ziel damit erreicht. Also ja, die sind schon ganz pfiffig da. Das muss man ihnen lassen.
Okay, wie wie geht's denn jetzt weiter? Also, das heißt jetzt, es gab diese einstweilige Verfügung von Sony gegen,
mit gesprochen. Ihr äh unterstützt da jetzt bei der bei der juristischen Antwort und dann dann wird dann dann geht man ja quasi.
Wie heißt das Fach? Man man fechtet die äh einstweilige Verfügung an, oder?
Genau, also wir ähm äh reichen Widerspruch ein äh dagegen oder beziehungsweise haben wir schon gemacht. Ähm
die das heißt, dass jetzt erstmal das Landgericht Hamburg
dadrüber entscheiden muss. Also die kriegen jetzt zum ersten Mal die komplette Faktenlage und nicht nur die eine Seite der Geschichte äh und die können jetzt also ihre Entscheidung nochmal überprüfen,
Allerdings sind das dann erstmal dieselben Richterinnen und Richter, die auch die einstweilige Verfügung verhängt haben. Ähm und insofern.
Und des Landgerichts Hamburg ist auch äh Aktenkundig, ne?
Also das Landgericht Hamburg ist auf jeden Fall bekannt als äh sehr rechteinhaberfreundlich und das ist möglicherweise auch der Grund, weshalb äh Sony die ihren Sitz in München haben gegen eine schweizer Stim
Stunden in Hamburg klagen, also das äh ist auch so eine Sache. Ähm,
ja kann man sich kann man sich dann seine Zeit zu denken aber da endet die Reise nicht. Also wir haben jetzt erstmal das Kostenrisiko für übernommen,
weil also falls eben dieser Widerspruch in der ersten Instanz äh noch nicht erfolgreich sein soll, auch erstmal kosten auf sie zukommen.
Ähm dann gibt's eben die Möglichkeit, äh erstmal gegen diese Entscheidung über die einstweilige Verfügung in Berufung zu gehen. Das wäre dann, glaube ich, das Oberlandesgericht Hamburg. Und es gibt eben auch die Möglichkeit, also wenn.
Diese einstweilige Verfügung aufrechterhalten wird, dann muss danach in der Hauptsache,
da drüber verhandelt werden. Also das bedeutet, dann gibt's ein richtiges Gerichtsverfahren. Also so funktioniert das eigentlich immer bei diesen Eilverfahren, dass halt erstmal,
'ne Entscheidung im Einfallfallen getrifft getroffen wird und die wird dann entweder akzeptiert oder halt in diesem Fall wenn sie wenn's 'n Widerspruch gibt,
dann äh gibt es dagegen dann später einen Hauptsache Verfahren, also das ist dann ganz normales, ordentliches Gerichtsverfahren mit mündlicher Verhandlung und so weiter,
Das heißt also das Thema wird uns noch eine Weile begleiten ähm das Kostenrisiko ist sehr hoch, weil ähm.
Wie das halt also man kennt das ja, wie das, wie das so ist bei Urheberrechtsstreitigkeiten, dass da oft äh dann auch äh ja Mutmaßungen darüber getroffen werden, wie hoch der potenzielle Schaden ist und anhand dessen wird dann der Streitwert festgesetzt,
Der ist äh also Streitwert in diesem Verfahren ist, glaube ich, hunderttausend Euro. Das heißt, äh äh daran berechnen sich dann die Gerichtskosten, die Anwaltskosten und so weiter.
Also erstmal ein relativ großes Kostenrisiko und wie teuer es dann wird hängt am Ende davon ab ob Quad9 gewinnt oder verliert,
und dieses Risiko wollten wir ihn halt nehmen, also das heißt, wir machen einerseits die juristische Unterstützung, ähm wir klären über den Fall auf,
und äh wir übernehmen das Kostenrisiko bei der Sache. Und äh da sind wir natürlich immer.
Für Unterstützung aus der Community dankbar. Also man kann Fördermitglied werden bei der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte,
und äh hilft damit eben also nicht nur dieses Gerichtsverfahren, sondern auch viele andere grundrechtliche äh Klagen von uns äh zu finanzieren.
Super, Julia, vielen Dank für die äh Ausführung und ich hoffe, mit eurer Klage geht's gut voran.
Ja, danke euch.
Dann werden wir diesmal, weil du äh viel beschäftigt bist, dich heute mal vorzeitig aus der Sendung entlassen und Tim und ich machen jetzt äh mal ohne dich weiter, ne.
So
Viel Spaß.
Du bist ja noch relativ busy. Äh und äh ja, viel Erfolg und wir werden den Fall hier weiter begleiten.
Bis dann, tschüss.
Bis dahin, ciao ciao. So, dann schauen wir mal, was sonst noch so passiert ist, wenn wir eher so ein paar.
Kleinere Meldungen, die wir aber trotzdem mit euch teilen wollen, so klein sind die nämlich auch nicht, erfordern vielleicht nicht ganz so viel Erörterung, wie wir es äh in dem Thema jetzt gerade hatten.
Und zwar gibt es einen Terrorvorwurf gegen das Aktionskunstkollektiv Peng. Die.
Das ist ja immer die höchste Auszeichnung, die man so als Künstler äh Kollektiv bekommen kann, ne?
Ja, ja, auf jeden Fall. Also das ist eine hohe Auszeichnung, die geht aber dummerweise mit echt äh also der Preis ist hoch, ja.
Wenn nur oft irgendwie in diesen Terrorlisten landest, dass äh das äh ist, da willste nicht drauf. Ja, also das ist das ist so ein Preis
für den wird man nominiert und den lehnt man aber dann ab. Ne? Also so der Terrorismus, ja.
Ja, der äh kürzt kurzzeitig äh ein mediales Strohfeuer. Also was haben die gemacht? Das ist schon relativ lange her, wenn ich das richtig äh erinnere, war das irgendwie letztes Jahr oder sogar das Jahr davor.
Dass sie eine Webseite gemacht haben unter Tier this down dot com,
Ja, da gab es also äh und das ist nicht unbedingt etwas, was auf äh Deutschland äh beschränkt war. Äh wir alle wissen ja, dass es seit einiger Zeit
ähm diese Bewegung äh black lives matter gibt, die in den USA sehr wichtige äh politische Themen äh in den Vordergrund bringt und dort eine Benachteiligung,
ähm schwarzen Bevölkerung zeigt die sich eben,
seit ja Jahrhunderten dort hält, äh die sich zum Beispiel in der unterschiedlichen Behandlung durch die Polizei, in der unterschiedlichen äh sozioökonomischen Situation und in äh natürlich auch in den.
Tötungsfällen widerspiegelt George Floyd, um dann nur mal ein Stichwort zu nennen,
In diesem Kontext gab es, wenn ich das jetzt richtig äh erinnere, in den USA dann auch ähm so eine so verschiedene Aktionen, wo.
Südstapler-Denkmäler angegriffen wurden. Also wir wissen, es gab in den USA einen Bürgerkrieg zwischen,
den ja nördlichen Staaten und den südlichen Staaten, ähm bei dem es um eine ganze Menge ging, aber eben unter anderem auch, um.
Sklavenhaltung,
dass die Südstaaten äh sehr ökonomisch davon profitiert haben, Menschen zu versklaven, klar, ne? Also es man muss auch sehr dumme Menschen können mit Hilfe von Versklavungen sehr gute ökonomische Vorteile
erlangen und ähm dann eben.
Die Auseinandersetzung, die am Ende eben in dem äh also in der, in dem Verbot der Sklaverei gemündet hat. So,
Jetzt haben die Südstapler quasi für einige der äh der generelle oder sonstigen äh Helden des Kampfes für die Freiheit der Sklaverei. Ähm.
Denkmäler aufgestellt. Und ähm natürlich ist es, denke ich mal, angemessen sich im Jahr.
2020 oder 19 endlich mal die Frage zu stellen, ob man ein solches Denkmal denn da stehen haben möchte, ob man solche Menschen ehren möchte, die für Menschen verachtende äh Systeme standen. Ähm,
ähnlich dann auch eine äh der die Aktion von Peng,
die sagen, es ist zwanzig20, also es soll genau 2020 war die Aktion Kolonialismus hat keinen Platz auf unseren Straßen. So und da gibt es natürlich auch in Deutschland eine ganze Reihe an.
Ähm ja kolonialem Erbe, was,
in Deutschland ähm stattfindet, ja? Es gibt zum Beispiel in Berlin eine Straße, die auch eine U-Bahn-Station hat, die äh regelmäßig ähm umbenannt wird in Mörchenstraße und ähnliches,
weil sie eben einen Namen hat, der sagen wir mal, nicht angemessen ist.
Heute aus heutiger Perspektive nicht angemessen ist.
Genau und das ist ja auch also ne, das ist ja schlimm genug, dass es damals angemessen war und dann kann man sich eben heute damit überlegen.
Kann man sich heute überlegen, dass man da vielleicht auch einfach mal eine ein Anerkenntnis.
Leistet. So, also haben sie gesagt, wir machen eine Karte.
Ähm auf der koloniale Spuren gesammelt werden,
Ja? Kann man melden äh und dann wird gesagt, okay, also sie rufen hier dazu auf, erstens die Verantwortung zu übernehmen, die Perspektive zu wechseln, beispielsweise durch eine Umbenennung und eben.
Kämpferinnen empowern, ja? Das äh.
Äh also für einen öffentlichen Raum zu sorgen, in dem schwarze Menschen und Menschen of Color nicht an Leid und Gewalt erinnern wer erinnert werden, sondern sich empowert fühlen.
Außerdem sagen sie, jetzt weg damit, was können wir tun, markieren, aufarbeiten, erinnern.
Also, sie sagen, äh wenn die Denkmäler gefallen sind, soll keine Erinnerungslücke bleiben, sondern eben, ne, die Kolonialgeschichte darf nicht aus dem Stadtbild verschwinden, ne? Grausamkeit des Kolonialismus muss sichtbar gemacht werden, aber eben auch in einer Form.
Die das dies eben aufarbeitet. Daran haben sich beteiligt 'ne ganze Reihe an lokalen Initiativen und Vereinen und.
'ne Karte auf der Karte kannst du diese ja diese Dinge eben sehen,
ist es offenbar passiert, ähm dass sich äh einige Gruppen auch äh gegen oder unbekannte Gruppen auf jeden Fall nach meiner nach meinem Verständnis. Ähm.
Äh sage ich mal, direkt äh hier ohne Beschluss des Stadtrates daran gemacht haben, äh diese existierenden Denkmäler äh abzuwandeln.
Um hier den Prozess zu beschleunigen. Und äh das fällt dann natürlich unter in dem Bereich des äh der Sachbeschädigung.
Und äh wenn man dann sagt, oh, das sind aber potenziell Linke, dann ist das eben nicht mehr Sachbeschädigung, sondern Terrorismus. Und äh hier wird dann jetzt.
Ja, so so läuft das, ne, das kennen wir
Und äh ja, da so konnte das Pain-Kollektiv eben der Berichterstattung der Süddeutschen Zeitung äh der einer kleinen, einer schriftlichen Anfrage von Niklas Schreder äh und äh,
Berichterstattung der TAZ glaube ich auch entnehmen, dass das Berliner LKA empfohlen hat, dass Künstlerinnen Kollektiv Peng auf die bundesweite Terrorliste des Verfassungsschutzes aufzunehmen
Und das wurde bestätigt von der Staatssekretärin der Justiz von Berlin gegenüber.
Und zwar weil sie und jetzt die Begründung ist, sie hätten gemeinsam mit der Initiative Schwarzer Menschen in Deutschland äh eine Webseite Tier des down dot com,
betrieben und diese würde zu Straftaten aufrufen.
Ähm kann ich äh kann ich jetzt auf ersten Blick nicht erkennen, wobei natürlich äh als Kunstwebseite sie selbstverständlich damit spielt und sagt diese äh diese ähm.
Denkmäler müssen weichen. Tja, ähm,
Ich denke schon, dass man hier natürlich in dem Bereich der der Kunstfreiheit ist, so. Wenn wir das noch nicht mal mehr machen darfst und sagst, du möchtest hier irgendwie koloniales Erbe in Deutschland aufarbeiten und bist dann auf einmal wirst dann auf einmal des Aufrufs zu Straftaten beschuldigt. Äh da gehen wir wirklich ein bisschen
äh zu weit. Und äh insofern mache ich darauf äh aufmerksam, dass hier äh denke ich ein beispielloser.
Vorgang gerade stattfindet, der Aufmerksamkeit benötigt.
Auch wieder ein schönes Beispiel für diesen völlig.
Aufgeblasenen und unangemessenen äh Nutzung dieses Begriffs Terror, nicht? Also wenn auf der einen Seite alles Mögliche mit Terror,
legitimiert wird, ja so, ja, aber Terror, kann man sagen, so, ja, aber auch, aber die Künstler, ja, es gibt ja Künstler und deswegen, äh, müssen wir da, äh, mit dicken, fetten Bazookas draufhalten.
Das ist wirklich äh und und da musst du dann vielleicht auch mal sagen, ne, das sind also.
Das ist genau der Bereich von Kunst, Freiheit und Meinungsfreiheit, ja? Das eine Künstlergruppe eben sagen kann, hier, das ist ein Missstand,
oder dass auch Menschen sagen können, das ist ein Missstand, ohne dass man sie am Ende dafür verantwortlich macht, dass es andere Menschen gibt, die aufgrund dieses Missstandes potenziell eben äh unterschiedliche ähm,
Aktionen.
Durchführen, die potenziell illegal sind, aber auch, sorry, das Beschädigen eines Denkmals, das äh ist halt kein Terrorismus.
Ja? Äh es ist potenziell Terrorismus, wenn man an äh bestimmte Denkmäler verfassungsfeindliche ähm symbole sprüht, ja, wie es ja.
Mit äh entsprechenden äh Denkmälern und Mahnmälern, äh die sich mit äh dem Dritten Reich befassen, regelmäßig der Fall ist, ne? Da kann man von einer verfassungsfeindlichen Organisation sprechen, da kann man von der Verwendung ähm,
verfassungsfeindlicher Symbole sprechen. Äh wir haben in Deutschland äh große Aufwendungen äh für den Polizeiapparat um jüdische Einrichtungen zu schützen, ne? Da kann man da kann man irgendwann mal von Terrorismus sprechen.
Ja, aber wenn jetzt irgendjemand ein Graffiti an an äh irgend so ein Kolonialdenkmal macht, dann ist das, glaube ich, kein Terrorismus.
Ja, das äh ist es natürlich nicht.
Es reicht nicht, wenn du eine Sammlung davon machst, was ja auch durchaus mal also muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, hat ja auch dokumentarischen Anspruch
zu sagen, übrigens hier, das gibt es. Ich habe zum Beispiel, also muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe in der Schule nix äh von deutschen äh Kolonien gelernt,
Und dass das irgendwie falsch wäre.
Nee, das ist in der Tat unterrepräsentiert.
Ne? Und äh das ist etwas, was ich später selber gelernt habe durch eine durch eine Auseinandersetzung, wo Menschen das an mich herangetragen haben. Und genau das ist ja die Arbeit, die das Penkollektiv hier eben auch leistet.
Auf jeden Fall auch eine
eine wertvolle Tätigkeit, die getan werden muss und überhaupt muss der Kunst einfach diese Freiheit auch gegeben werden. Ich erinnere mich auch an diese
wahnsinnig großartigen äh Aktionen, die einst klingen. Christoph auch.
Da losgetreten hat, also so was auch unter Terror abzuspeichern, kommt einem total äh absurd vor, als er da irgendwie alle Arbeitslosen, an den
äh See äh gebeten hat, in Wolfgangssee, wo Helmut Kohl auf der anderen Seite äh Urlaub gemacht hat. Ja, dass sich noch an die Aktion.
Sie auch alle sehr unruhig geworden so. So ja alle Arbeitslosen jetzt an den See, wir schwimmen jetzt rüber zum Kohl,
Oder diese großartige Aktion in Wien, wo er dann irgendwie so Big Brother äh Style so eine Show gemacht hat, Ausländer raus, wo er
die Ausländer sollen jetzt hier rausgewählt werden wie bei
Brother. Und das ist das ist einfach so die die wirklich die die das scharfe Messer, was da in die Wunde äh gelegt wird so, ja, das tut dann halt extrem weh, aber natürlich kannst du sie halt vielleicht auch ein Stück weit wieder verschließen, indem man einfach diese,
Sache oder auch so öffentlich macht.
Ja äh schlingen sie schwer. Also genau, da muss dann auch mal, da muss dann auch mal der Geschmack äh auf die Probe gestellt werden bei solchen.
Genau. Genau. Next.
Okay, dann haben wir ähm zunächst, also das sind noch keine bestätigten.
Eindeutig bestätigten Berichte, aber ähm was die USA offenbar in ähm.
In äh Afghanistan verwendet haben, sind biometrische Systeme.
Ähm also ähm sieht man hier so irgendwelche äh ja im weitesten Sinne Kameras, wo sie dann Bilder von den Menschen machen, sie müssen ihre Augen weit aufhalten und ähm,
Fingerabdrücke natürlich von den Menschen genommen und.
Es ist wird eben berichtet, dass die äh Taliban.
Diese biobiometrischen Tools jetzt in ihre oder diese biometrischen Datenbanken in ihre Finger bekommen und nutzen könnte.
Um die Ortskräfte ähm und ja Kollaborature und so weiter äh zu suchen,
und ihrer ähm.
Ja, dem dem Verfahren angedeihen zu lassen, dass das diesen Menschen äh jetzt droht. Ähm.
Wie gesagt, bisher ist das äh von der Gruppe äh wie heißt sie.
Human Rights Watch? Nee, Human Rights First. Äh die warnen davor, dass das der Fall ist und na ja, zeigt natürlich sehr klar äh auch und also es würde mich nicht wundern,
wenn so etwas geschieht, ja? Oder irgendwelche digitale Erfassung von Kollaberateuren, Erzkräften, Informantinnen und so weiter hier
dann in die in die Hände der Taliban fällt und zu Problemen führt. Warum ist das also
Das ist natürlich ein großes Problem, deswegen benutzt man solche Systeme nicht. Ähm gleichzeitig gibt's da eine sehr interessante Parallele.
Zu äh den ganzen Geschichten,
war damals also so richtig drangekommen sind die, als aus den Efgen äh Warlocks, die ähm,
Die unzensierten Versionen bekannt wurden, ja? Wir haben die Geschichte hier öfters erzählt, dass da daran da hatte keine Schuld,
ähm sondern es war eine, ja, eine Verkettung.
Im weitesten Sinne tragischer Umstände, die dazu geführt hat, weil ein Guardian-Journalist in seinem Buch über diese Wikileak Sachen ausgerechnet das Passwort für eine verschlüsselte Datei.
Als als Überschrift genommen hat und darin geschildert hat, was weiß ich, es gab eine Datei, die war so und so groß, die war verschlüsselt und das Passwort lautete,
Ja und zwischendurch hatte sich aber Wiki Leaks aufgrund vielfältiger Dedosangriffe wurden sie halt gemüt und da ist diese Datei quasi auch in,
in die Hände der Weltöffentlichkeit gelangt, aber das Passwort war so lang, dass es halt einfach keine nicht zur Diskussion stand, die zu entschlüsseln. Da hat aber jemand das Buch gelesen, hat gedacht, hm, eine sechs Gigabyte Datei von WikiLeaks, habe ich doch hier oder ich weiß nicht, ob die sechs war oder zwanzig. Ähm
und hat das Passwort eingegeben und hat dann gesehen, oh, da sind die redigierten Dinger drin. Und diese Gefährdung.
Der Kollaboratorinnen und Ortskräfte in Afghanistan, im Irak. Das war das, was Wikileaks immer,
vorgeworfen wurde, was die Grenzüberschreitung war, was was die getan hätten, ja? Und womit man das die die Organisation dann eben dauerhaft in Misskredit äh gebracht hat. Und jetzt hast du die Situation, dass es potenziell,
im Raum steht, dass das einfach mit der Datenerfassung äh der USA in Afghanistan jetzt in die in die Hände des Feindes gefallen ist.
Da muss man mal gucken, was aus dem Gerücht dann auch wird. Ich meine, wenn man schon so ein System aufsetzt, ich frag mich jetzt an welcher Stelle das denn überhaupt betrieben wurde, dass es quasi überhaupt in deren Hand äh fallen kann, weil es ja jetzt nicht so, dass sie da.
Ihre Serverinfrastruktur einfach zurücklassen und dann nicht in der Lage sind, da Daten
sozusagen verfallen zu lassen. Im Idealfall ist sowas ja auch verschlüsselt und wenn man dann halt äh irgendeinen Stecker äh äh zieht, ist der Schlüssel weg und äh alles ist nicht mehr zu benutzen
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen unrealistisch. Ähm obwohl genauso müsste man's eigentlich machen.
Ja, also du musst dir halt vorstellen, also in ähm also in Ländern, in denen,
so eine Personenerfassungsinfrastruktur, wie sie in Deutschland äh im weitesten Sinne existiert, noch nicht vorhanden ist. Also nehmen wir Indien, ja? Da werden, werden jeden Tag eine ganze Reihe Menschen geboren, ohne dass.
Die jetzt irgendwo in der Bürokratie erfasst werden, ne? Ähm nehmen wir,
zum Beispiel eben Land mit mit ja mehr oder weniger offenbar sehr instabilen Regierungsverhältnissen. Und da sind diese ähm.
Da sind diese Biometriesysteme natürlich von sehr großen Interesse.
Man sagt, okay, damit können wir echt Leute einmalig identifizieren und dann wieder identifizieren.
Unabhängig davon, dass diese Systeme natürlich auch gar nicht so fehlerunanfällig sind, äh wie die sich das äh wie sie es versprechen. Aber ja.
Aber an diesem System wurde vor allem auch nicht sicherstellen kannst, wo du keine Ausweise ausgeben kannst, die dann nicht.
Die Leute nicht dabei haben und zwar es kann ja auch von durchaus von Vorteil sein für die Leute, ne, sozusagen äh erkannt werden zu zu können, aber es hat natürlich auch die üblichen Nachteile.
Und ja, jetzt, wie gesagt, also die Sorge äh nähert sich in Afghanistan, ist sowieso eine ganze, also die Reihe an in der Reihe an Fehlern
in Afghanistan ist das jetzt nur einer, aber natürlich für uns von Interesse, weil,
hier in Deutschland ja auch biometrische Systeme ausgerollt werden. Wir haben jetzt gerade den Stichtag überschritten, bei dem.
Äh das Abgeben von Fingerabdrücken bei der Beantragung eines Personalausweises nicht mehr optional ist. Personalausweise sind zehn Jahre gültig. Das heißt, in zehn Jahren,
hat die Bundesrepublik Deutschland ähm von allen Bundesbürgern die Fingerabdrücke,
die äh in dem Alter sind, dass sie sich einen Ausweis holen. Wann holt man sich den mit 14 oder sowas?
Ähm ich weiß gar nicht, ab wann man einen bekommen kann. Personalausweis mal so in Deutschland. Ähm ich schaue mal kurz.
Aber in spätestens zehn Jahren äh war es soweit. Vorausgesetzt, dass jetzt äh Verfassungsbeschwerden und ähnliches, die dagegen gehen ähm äh ins Leere laufen.
Seit dem 1. November 207 können Personalausweise bereits mit der Geburt eines Kindes, also auch für Jugendliche unter 16 Jahren beantragt werden.
Okay, aber ja gut, das wird man dann vom, also ich gehe davon aus, dass Menschen jetzt versuchen werden, dass äh noch ein bisschen ähm,
fernzuhalten, ja? Aber äh genau, ich hatte da jetzt auch nochmal kürzlich ein äh ähm
einen Sachverständigenauskunft im Innenausschuss zu dieser EID Novelle, wo ja außerdem dann auch noch der der weitreichende obliquitäre Zugriff auf diese Daten äh geklärt werden soll. Das heißt, dass dass die Eliten werden, haben wir auch relativ bald.
Ja? Dass äh da kannst du dich jetzt schon drauf vorbereiten, dass im Prinzip dein äh Fingerabdruck äh kein Geheimnis mehr ist.
Oh Gott, oh Gott, diekt ja dann auch der Datenschleuder irgendwann bei?
Deiner auf jeden Fall, Tim.
Scheiße.
Ähm so, es gibt.
Allerdings im Bereich der Cyber-Sicherheit auch grade mal eine ganz positive Meldung und zwar äh unterhält der Iran.
Ein Gefängnis mit dem Namen Evan. Ähm in dem offenbar ähm Folter,
stattfindet. Und dieses Gefängnis wurde,
gehackt von einer Gruppe mit dem Namen Ederlad E-Ali, Alis Gerechtigkeit übersetzt und die haben offenbar sogar die äh,
oder die haben offenbar die Videokameras übernommen. Du siehst zum Beispiel ein Video aus dem Überwachungsraum.
Ähm und da sie offenbar ihre äh Folter dort auch aufzeichnen, äh mit diesen Videokameras geben die Angreifer an, sie hätten äh hunderte Gigabyte an Daten,
ähm aus den Jahren 2020021 Menschen tragen auf den Videoaufzeichnungen Artenschutzmasken, was darauf äh also,
darauf hindeutet, dass das tatsächlich so aus dieser Zeit ist, weil das ja erst seit so Anfang 2020 modern geworden ist, äh sowas zu machen.
Und.
Äh die der Chef des iranischen, der iranischen Justiz, hat ähm auch die Echtheit der Aufnahmen bestätigt.
Das ist natürlich ähm krass, weil die damit eben Menschenrechtsverletzungen eingeräumt haben und das natürlich auch bedeutet, dass äh dass das hoffentlich Konsequenzen haben wird.
Ciao.
Vor allem für die für die interne äh IT
Ich meine, dieser ganze Zugang zu Überwachungskameras ist natürlich wirklich ein, ein, ein interessanter Angriffsvektor grade im Nachweis von äh Kriminellen Verhalten, ne, oder in diesem Fall sogar Menschenrechtsschädlichem Verhalten
was ja im Internet auch ein beliebter Sport ist, wirst du wahrscheinlich auch schon mal mitbekommen haben, dass diese ganzen äh Internetscammer vor allem aus Indien, ja, die Leute irgendwie.
Anrufen und ihn behaupten, ihr Computer wäre jetzt im Eimer und dann geben sie irgendwelche äh äh Bankzugangsdaten ein, wäre
dann halt das äh Gerät von außen schon voll überwacht wird, sodass die dann eben sich die Kohle äh rüberholen. Und die gibt's ja jetzt so den diesen Sport im Netz von Leuten, die dann wiederum diese ausfindig machen.
Äh und äh ich kenne so mehrere Fälle, wo sie dann auch es geschafft haben, genau den Ort zu finden, wo die alle sitzen, in Indien und dann auch ins Netz reingegangen sind und dann denen,
über Video live zuschauen konnten, wenn während sie versucht haben, den anderen äh zu scannen und das eben äh darüber nachgewiesen haben
dass die das sind, also das ist äh jetzt ganz interessant, dass das diese zunehmende volldigitalisierung auch von äh rechtsstaatlich nicht geradeaus laufenden Organisationen jetzt äh.
Auch in äh für sie eine Gefahr darstellt.
Das gutes gutes ja das kann man da kann man sich nochmal richtig austoben. Kriminelle und menschenrechtsverachtende zu hacken da da kann man nochmal so richtig schön nach Lust und Laune.
Man sollte sich das zweimal überlegen, wenn man sich bitter iranischen Regierung anlegt.
Ja, das ist aber auch äh äh ich sage mal,
es gibt Länder, äh die man, sage ich mal, die jetzt nicht so tragisch sind, wenn man da nicht hinreisen darf, ja. Die USA würde mir mehr ausmachen, wenn ich da nicht mehr hinreisen kann, als jetzt beispielsweise die Türkei, wo ich nicht mehr hinreisen kann
Ja, das ist Iran hatte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt auf der Liste. Ich höre davon, dass es supernette Leute sind, aber ähm.
Da sind mir irgendwie die die politischen Verhältnisse einfach nicht äh.
Politische Verhältnisse können sich ja auch irgendwann wieder ändern, also vielleicht nicht gleich alle Optionen, ne.
Ja gut, dann, dann ist aber auch vielleicht nicht das Problem, dass man da mal einen Folterknast aufgemacht hat, ne.
Ja, insofern temporäre temporäre Einreise Umgehungsnotwendigkeit für den Iran ist OK, ja?
Ein paar andere Länder besuchen.
Wollte nur kurz eine Warnung aussprechen.
Ja. Kann natürlich auch sein, dass die dass die Amis hier ihre Militärbasen abbauen und die Taliban einreitet und dass das Ganze in zehn Minuten hier vorbei ist mit der Bundesrepublik.
Ja, gut, dann ist eh vorbei.
Eine Scheiße. Aber zum Glück äh haben wir äh heute sind wir damit nicht auf der äh oder in dieser in diesen Wochen sind wir mal nicht auf der äh höchsten Skala der schlechtesten Nachrichten, die ihr.
So und dann haben wir eine neue äh Beschwerdewelle von Noib. Ne, unsere Freunde aus Österreich, die Organisation,
von Mit und Um Max Shrems.
Und die haben jetzt äh Datenschutzbeschwerden gegen eine ganze Reihe an Medienunternehmen eingelegt. Ähm zum Beispiel Spiegelzeit Online, Reise OnlinefuZs und T-Online und Krone AT.
Und das ist etwas, was ihr sicherlich auch kennt und zwar diese diese Meldung, dass man ein Pura-Abo abschließen solle.
Der man Werbung und bei der auf Werbung und verzichtet wird?
Und ähm oder man die Seite unentgeltlich nutzen kann.
Dafür aber Werbung und Tracking akzeptieren muss. Das ist unabhängig von dem Generellen äh Abo.
Ähm was zum Beispiel beim Spiegel jetzt äh Spiegel Plus heißt, was einem ermöglicht, die Artikel zu sehen, ne? Das sind also zwei unterschiedliche,
Angebote. Als ich mal
so ein Plus-Abo getestet habe, war ich eben auch verwundert, dass ich für für äh für den Preis, den ich da zahle, immer noch Werbung sehen muss und es tatsächlich so, dass jetzt zum Beispiel über Spiegel Online, wenn du Spiegel Plus hast
Ist er immer noch mit Werbung? Dann muss er 1 99 extra zahlen, um die Werbung auch noch loszuwerden.
Und gleichzeitig, wenn du kein Spiegelplus hast und nur die kostenlosen Artikel ohne Werbung sehen willst, musst du vier neunundneunzig bezahlen. Und äh.
Finde ich jetzt ein bisschen äh krass.
Sportlich, ist auch ist aber nicht nur beim Spiel so, ist übrigens auch bei Heise so.
Ich habe, das ist äh korrekt, ähm heiße wehrt sich nur nicht gegen meinen AdBlocker.
Spiegel macht das glaube ich ein bisschen äh bisschen eleganter oder ein bisschen technisch äh besser. Ich glaube, die laden die Werbung inzwischen einfach von den gleichen Servern, wo sie auch ihre Bilder herholen oder so. Ich habe mir das länger nicht mehr angeschaut.
Now. Genau.
Okay und da,
beschwert sich jetzt noch. Ich nehme jetzt als Beispiel, ja, wir haben viele genannt, ihr kennt die auch alle und geht ja einfach direkt an alle, äh ja und das sind äh sehr viele ähm.
Ich habe das jetzt hier, ob die Beschwerde gegen den Spiegel und die Berichterstattung des Spiegels mal beispielhaft äh verlinkt.
Und äh neu ab argumentiert in der Beschwerde über den Spiegel, auf die durch das Tracking gesammelten Daten haben bis zu 190 und,
unmittelbaren und weitere hunderte, wenn ich tausende Unternehmen mittelbaren Zugriff. Die gesamte Kette des Datenhandels wird zu keinem Zeitpunkt nachvollziehbar offengelegt.
Und äh damit sagen sie äh,
Gleichzeitig sagen sie also okay, dieser Teil ist sowieso schon mal nicht in Ordnung. Und durch diese Pur-Abo-Sache
erzwingen sie ja die Einwilligung. Also du gehst auf die Seite, dann steht da hallo, sie sind das erste Mal hier, es gibt pur oder es gibt mit Werbung und dann musst du dem zustimmen. Ja? Und da sagen sie jetzt äh die diese 499 sind Wucher,
praktischen Aufwand verbunden und damit ist ähm.
Quasi diese äh dieses Angebot, vor das sie dich da stellen, nicht nicht angemessen, ja? Äh neu äh sagt dann die Medienhäuser, äh verdienen.
Direkt gebuchter und meist nicht personalisierter Werbung sehr gutes Geld, die Restplätze werden dann irgendwie an Google und Co für ein paar Cent
verscherbelt und damit gehen dann eben auch die Nutzerdaten direkt an diese Konkurrenz, die eben dann diesen Kuchen äh für sich behält.
Und jetzt argumentieren sie, naja, diese zielgerichtete Werbung, die macht ihr eh nicht selber, da kriegt ihr auch nur Cents von.
Aber bei dem äh äh,
Pur Abo macht ihr eben äh enormen Umsatz äh mit den Leuten, um diese um diese Option zu umgehen.
Und da argumentiert Allah, der Datenschutzjurist von Leub, die Leute müssen mitunter, dass zehn, zwanzig oder hundertfache zahlen, damit ihre Daten nicht mehr weitergegeben würden.
Man bekommt den Eindruck und dem kann ich auch von der Argumentation her folgen, dass es nicht um eine faire Alternative zur Einwilligung geht.
Sondern darum, äh, teure Abos zu verkaufen oder eben die Einwilligung durch 'ne, durch 'ne teure Alternative de facto zu erzwingen.
Und das äh muss ich auch sagen, diese Purdinger sind sind wirklich,
nicht nicht angenehm. Die sind wirklich ein juckender Ausschlag. Vor allem, wenn man ähm,
wie ich Cookies nicht lange behält und das immer wieder neu da klicken muss und so das irgendwie nervig.
Der Spiegel entgegnet, wie gesagt, wir nehmen exemplarisch den Spiegel. Oh, haben sie aber sich sehr viel Platz eingeräumt in ihrem eigenen Artikel. Na ja, äh Artikel. Na ja, also der Spiegel teilt dazu mit,
und stehen dort jederzeit zu Gesprächen über zur Verfügung, so wie wir auch bei früheren Nachfragen transparent über diesen Lösungsansatz diskutiert haben, über den Preispunkt
reden wir selbst intern regelmäßig und starten ohnehin gerade Tests im Markt, ob wir in generell auch für Nichtabonnentinnen senken sollten. Die Kalkulation, die Neubau.
Krank, allerdings daran, dass man sich mit Pur keineswegs nur Tracking-Freiheit kauft,
sondern fast vollständige Werbefreiheit. Da sagen sie also, na, das das sehen sie natürlich dann als äh also das verkaufen sie dir jetzt hier, als als Mehrwert.
Für den der für sie rechtfertigt das das teurer zu machen. Ein ein gedruckter Spiegel ohne Werbung wäre auch viel teurer als einer mit Anzeigen.
Äh
Ja.
Ich glaube, der nicht alles, was hinkt ist ein ist ein Vergleich,
Man muss natürlich auch die ökonomische äh Realität äh berücksichtigen. Und wenn ein gedruckter Spiegel ohne Werbung nun mal genauso teuer wäre
für euch in der Auslieferung und in der Produktion, dann könnte man eben nicht argumentieren, warum der sehr viel teurer sein muss, ne.
Da der gedruckte Spiegel äh mit Werbung, der der äh schreibt sich aber auch nicht auf, wo ich gerade sitze, während ich ihn lese.
Genau und der gedruckte Spiegel ohne Werbung wäre auch echt um einiges dünner, ne. Muss man auch mal sagen.
Also das ist ein Ad leichthinkender Vergleich. Äh.
Und tja, aber damit argumentieren sie ja eigentlich, also was ich auch geil finde, fast vollständige Werbefreiheit. Also ich kriege noch nicht mal vollständige Werbefreiheit für vier neunundneunzig.
Ne? Und das sind nur da habe ich noch nicht mal Spiegel Plus. Also das ist schon irgendwie ja. Ich glaube, da muss man mal über die Preisgestaltung reden. Und ähm würden die ihre Purabos für ein Euro rausballern, dann hätte ich die alle.
Ja und das äh da also muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, die hätte ich.
199 nimmst du sie nicht.
Eins neunundneunzig können wir können wir drüber verhandeln, ja?
Ach so, aber 4 99 für möchtest du nicht bezahlen, ja. Ja, nee, das.
Nicht bereit, nein. Und erst recht nicht und erst recht nicht eins neunundneunzig, wenn ich schon eh Spiegel Plus da habe. Ich weiß gar nicht, was Spiegel Plus kostet. Zehner oder was? Teuer, ne?
Zwanzig glaube ich sogar.
Also naja, da da bin ich mal gespannt. Also ich kann ich ich äh bin da generell bei Noib, dass man dass man dieses Vorgehen erscheint mir irgendwie nicht äh.
Aber das wird schon, wird schon spannend, diese Auseinandersetzung, ne, weil man kann ja nun auch nicht immer von allen äh verlangen, dass sie quasi ihre Dienstleistung kostenlos anbieten, ne? Die
zu welchen Bedingungen äh ist natürlich jetzt nochmal eine ganz andere Diskussion und es ist nun viel geworden. Lange Zeit ist ja den online Produktion
äh wie ich finde, auch zu Recht vorgeworfen worden, nicht sonderlich ähm ausprobierungswürdig zu sein. Man hat halt einfach gnadenlos auf Werbung und Trecker gesetzt, weil das war so eine totale Cashcow und in dem Moment, wo einfach diese ganzen Cookie und Etten
und so weiter noch nicht
waren, war das ja einfach ein wunderbares Geschäft, da hatten sie sozusagen überhaupt gar keine Probleme damit. Jetzt hat sich das natürlich über die Zeit geändert, auch durch das Aufkommen von von Melware, nicht wahr? Es war ja auch
zeitlang so, dass man dann einfach äh Werbung eingeblendet bekommen hat, die dann.
Injektionen, in die Webseite äh probiert hat, et cetera und musste sich sozusagen auch vorwerfen lassen, an der Stelle mal, wer mit äh auszuliefern oder zumindest dazu beizutragen, dass die ausgeliefert
wird, dann eben sehr zielgerichtet auf eben bestimmte Leute durch das ganze Werbetracking. Na ja und die dieser Stern sinkt jetzt eben so langsam. Er wird sicherlich nicht vollständig verschwinden, aber jetzt muss eben so eine
korrekter Verteilung zwischen so Mehrwert Inhalte bezahlen und eben okay. Wir haben ja auch ein Interesse dadran
Informationen quasi in Anführungsstrichen kostenlos zur Verfügung zu stellen, weil das ja auch was mit Sichtbarkeit durch Suchbarkeit indizierbarkeit äh zu tun hat und natürlich auch mit dem unmittelbaren Wettbewerb, mit
mit äh anderen Anbietern
ne, weil wenn du jetzt komplett zumachst, dann wirst du ja auch überhaupt nicht mehr gesehen, dann wirst du auch nicht mehr verlinkt. Das ist ja auch alles so ein Problem, auch ein ungelöstes äh Problem im Internet, trotz der entsprechenden HTTP. Status kurz, den da vielleicht unter Umständen hilfreich sein könnten. Und ähm,
denke, da sind wir noch lange nicht am Ende. Also das ist sicherlich ein Thema, was auch noch in fünf, vielleicht sogar auch in zehn Jahren noch äh immer wieder neu äh verhandelt werden muss, weil diese ganzen Businessmodelle.
Sich auch immer wieder neuen Bedingungen anpassen müssen.
Ja und ich, aber ich, also ich also wir sehen ja tatsächlich die ich weiß nicht, wann die angefangen haben mit ihrem äh Spiegel Plus und äh Zeitplus und Heise Plus und wie das alles heißt, ne?
Kamen so die letzten ein, zwei Jahren kam das.
Das kam irgendwie in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren auf und äh einige dieser Abos unterhalte ich auch selber, ja? Ähm,
Und was ich aber jetzt beobachte, ist ähm gerade beim Spiegel, in letzter Zeit wird einfach viel, viel mehr zu Plusinhalt, ne? Die haben das anfangs mal gemacht und so, guck mal, hier kriegt's noch was Schönes. Ähm da kannste äh Plus und
pur und hasse alles nicht gesehen. Und jetzt wird das zunehmend immer mehr.
Ja und auch die Topmeldungen und so, ne?
Genau und dass das auch meine Topmeldung betrifft und so.
In diesem Moment klicke ich gerade drauf und dann ist sozusagen die die Top Meldung auf der Homepage ist halt auch Spiegel Plus. Hm.
Und das ist, ich meine, das das bleibt denen ja unbenommen,
Ja, finde ich völlig in Ordnung. Was ich, ich finde es auch tatsächlich krass, dass sie dann noch diese Werbefreiheit noch,
extra dazu haben wollen. Also für die Preise, die diese Dinger kosten, ähm
Ist es, glaube ich, ein Zehner, bei Spiegel sagst du jetzt ein Zwanni. Äh woanders ist sieben Euro, wie auch immer, ne? Da muss man dann irgendwann einmal sagen, so komm, dann mach die Werbefreiheit da mit rein, dann mach doch einmal hier
die Bude ordentlich. Und diese Sachen nicht zu verbinden, das finde ich nicht okay.
Okay, aber gibt zwei Diskussionen. Die eine ist, äh ist das ist das.
Müssen ja auch getrennt werden.
Genau, ist das jetzt irgendwie, ist es mir zu teuer? Das ist letzten Endes Angebot und Nachfrage, der Markt entscheidet. So, das andere ist, werden jetzt hier irgendwie konkrete Rechte äh äh verletzt, ja, die nicht im Sinne des äh Datenschutzes äh sind. Und das,
dann sicherlich diese Klage von Herrn Shrimps und Co auch herausfinden.
Genau, die also deren Argumentation ist spezifisch, du willst dir Werbung wegkaufen, das wird dir oder die, du willst dir Tracking wegkaufen, das wird dir um einige äh um einiges teurer gemacht, als.
Das, was die damit verdienen. Und das ist der der Kern deren Beschwerde.
So, dann gibt es noch abschließend eine sehr äh interessante Meldung, die gar nicht so viel ähm.
Also da ist noch gar nicht so viel drin, ja? Und zwar hat sich offenbar der US-Präsident Biden mit den großen äh Konzernen getroffen, also Microsoft, Apple, Amazon.
Und sicherlich noch einigen mehr, äh um,
sich irgendwie Gedanken zu machen über IT-Sicherheit und die hätten ihm jetzt zugesagt, dass sie Milliarden für mehr IT-Sicherheit ausgeben. Und das ein sehr äh.
Spannender Satz von äh Joe Biden gefallen.
Realität ist, dass die meisten unserer kritischen Infrastrukturen vom privaten Sektor betrieben werden. Und die Regierung kann diese Herausforderung nicht allein bewältigen.
Das ist eine eine krasse Feststellung. Jetzt stellt sich immer die Frage, okay, was ist eine kritische Infrastruktur in wessen Hand? Muss die sein und so weiter, ne? Wer sind Zulieferer? Das ist ein sehr komplexes Ding. Aber überhaupt mal zuzugeben,
dass deine kritische Infrastruktur größtenteils in privater Hand ist und du von diesen Megakonzernen abhängig bist ähm,
Fand ich bemerkenswert.
Aber sicherlich nicht nur in den USA so.
Korrekt. Ja, jetzt man muss auch immer überlegen, was ist eine Infrastruktur, also wenn jetzt mit Apple redest, ich würde halt eigentlich sagen, Apple.
Sollte keine kritische Infrastruktur haben oder sein. Äh Microsoft.
Wird bald eine, klar oder ist auf dem besten Weg eine zu werden mit ihrem Office 365, ne? Und äh jetzt sagen sie Microsoft wollen in den kommenden fünf Jahren, 20 Milliarden US-Dollar investieren?
Um fortschrittliche Sicherheitslösungen schneller bereitstellen zu können.
Google, will zehn Milliarden in den nächsten zehn Milliarden US-Dollar in den nächsten fünf Jahren investieren ähm.
Und ähm irgendwie.
Um IT Security zu erhöhen und 1hunderttausend Amerikanern dabei helfen, von der Industrie anerkannte Zertifikate für digitale Fähigkeiten zu erwerben.
Das wäre schön, wenn ihr es in Deutschland auch mal machen würden, weil der Fachkräftemangel im Bereich der IT-Sicherheit, der ist natürlich enorm, ja? Und äh das äh sehe ich ja in meiner beruflichen Tätigkeit
äh täglich und das scheint mir dann schon klügerer Schritt zu sein. Amazon.
Hat großzügige Ankündigungen sich abgerungen, dass sie die IT Security Schulung, die das Unternehmen seinen äh Unternehmen seinen Mitarbeitern anbietet, auch der Öffentlichkeit kostenlos zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Ja? Äh bin ich mal gespannt. Geil, viel Spaß mit der Amazon-Schulung, wo drin steht, klick hier nicht und nicht da, ne? Das ist das ist, glaube ich, eine relativ äh äh eine relativ äh wohlfeile Zusage.
Äh und ja,
äh sehr spannend. Äh aber klar, Biden interessiert sich für diese gesamten Bereiche der IT-Sicherheit. Wir hatten diese Fälle mit den
mit der äh Benzinpipeline. Wir hatten jetzt äh mehrere äh Fälle, die komischen Ausgang hatten. Und ähm
warum ich aber, was man auch sagen muss, ist.
Dieser Satz, den er da sagt, der größere Teil der kritischen Infrastruktur liegt nicht mehr in unserer Hand, der wird sich durch diese,
durch diese Vereinbarung oder diesen Pakt oder was auch immer das jetzt ist der wird sich nicht ändern, sondern der wird sich konzentrieren, wenn Microsoft jetzt sagt, alles klar, wir investieren mal hier ein paar Milliarden in Sicherheit.
Und Apple das macht, äh dann passiert etwas, dass.
Und ich saß politisch ungern, aber was natürlich ich gerade seit längerer Zeit äh beobachte, dass.
Im Zweifelsfall die, die sichersten Infrastrukturen bereitstellen.
Warum sage ich das? Ein Beispiel, der ähm diese Exchange äh Schwachstellen.
Ähm ja in Deutschland auch sehr vielen Unternehmen Sorge gemacht haben. Rate mal, auf welchen äh Exchange Servern die als erstes gepatcht waren, natürlich auf den auch von Microsoft. Ähm.
Wenn wir uns anschauen, wer wahrscheinlich der sicherste Mailserver ist sicher im Sinne von Hacker kommt nicht rein, dann wird er von Google unterhalten
weil bei Google irgendwie ein paar Jahresgehalt Millionäre damit beschäftigt sind, dass dieser Gmail Dienst funktioniert und das,
wahrscheinlich der aus, ne, ist er hackbar
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit gegeben, dass man dort Schwachstellen findet, äh wahrscheinlich einer der am sichersten betriebenen Mailserver der Welt ist einfach, weil er von von einem Team aus Millionären
betreut wird, die über für sagen wir mal den Betrieb eines Mailservers relativ großzügige Ressourcen verfügen im Vergleich zu dem, was irgendein KMU sich selber aufsetzen kann.
Ähm.
Office dreihundertfünfundsechzig, ähnlicher Fall, ne? Das heißt, da geht es hin zu mehr IT-Sicherheit im Sinne von die Systeme funktionieren, so wie der, wie das Unternehmen, das sie bereitstellt, es möchte.
Aber eben potentiell ist jetzt der andere Punkt, zu weniger Datenschutz, weniger Daten, Souveränität ähm und äh weniger,
Freiheiten in der Gestaltung der IT für die Unternehmen, die es nutzen. Insofern haben diese Unternehmen natürlich einen sehr großen ähm finanziellen Vorteil davon, wenn sie jetzt, wenn wenn Google sagt, alles klar,
Wir bilden jetzt hundert.tausend Leute in IT-Security aus. Was meinst du, was denn da erzählt wird? Denen wird gesagt, nutze Gmail,
viel Spaß in der freien Wirtschaft sag Bescheid Unternehmen zu uns migriert hast dann kriegst du einen Bonus. Ja also das ist ja das was hier dann,
wahrscheinlich laufen wird.
Na ja, also wenn Joe Biden feststellt, dass sie äh Realität sei, dass die meisten der kritischen Infrastruktur in den USA von dem privaten Sektor betrieben wird, dann kann man wahrscheinlich für Deutschland auch nur festhalten,
dass äh das hier eigentlich ganz genauso ist, nur von den selben Betreibern, also von dem US-amerikanischen privaten Sektor betrieben wird. Also hier ähm haben wir noch nicht mal diese Möglichkeiten in dem selben Maße Einfluss zu nehmen
Ja, also die USA läuft im Wesentlichen auf Infrastruktur der USA, während halt Europa im Wesentlichen auch auf der Infrastruktur der USA läuft.
Das wird sich auch nicht so schnell ändern lassen. Ist nur, sagen wir mal, in dem Moment, wo es darum geht, die Realität zu akzeptieren. Sicherlich auch ein Teil der Wahrheit.
Und wie du schon richtig gesagt hast, so oder so muss man halt jetzt hier einfach auch mehr Ausbildung liefern. Wir haben's ja schon tausendmal besprochen mit der ganzen Wear
hier also zumindest mal das Grundverständnis für Backup und im Wiederanlaufen von System vermittelt werden, um zumindest schon mal Schlimmstes zu verhindern.
Ja. Aber wirtschaftlich ist das jetzt kein schwerwiegendes Zugeständnis äh dieser Unternehmen. Tja.
So, damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung angekommen, würde ich mal meinen, oder?
Genau, damit sind wir ähm Ende der Sendung und äh wünschen Noib und GF äh viel Erfolg in ihren weiteren Vorgehen.
Und willst du noch irgendwas loswerden.
Nö, aber wir gehen nächste Woche vielleicht noch ein bisschen auf Feedback ein, aber heute haben wir äh ein bisschen wenig Zeit. Du musst los und ähm ich muss auch bald los und das war's jetzt erst mal. Wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Alles klar, dann vielen Dank und bis dahin. Tschau, tschau.